oh hello everybody my name is markiplier
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to welcome to the game
I'm saying that multiple times just in
case I didn't get it right at the
beginning of the game so welcome
everybody we are going to get into this
a few things right off the bat I now
know that not only was i stupid before I
mean I'm not just talking generally
before I know that generally I was
stupid for the past 6 years that I've
been doing YouTube but it I was
generally stupid in the last one because
I missed over something very obvious
about this games is that the code can be
hidden in the text of literally any page
in the game so if you hover over every
single word of the page you will
eventually find some links so you have
to comb through each page with a
fine-tooth comb
not only looking for the link to the
second wiki which is generally pretty
obvious but there's also another deeper
level of it that I wasn't doing in
addition to that I now have an extensive
guide on the various wi-fi's because the
Wi-Fi mechanics are a bit of a mystery
but there is a spreadsheet that someone
made that details every single little
nuance of every single little Wi-Fi
network including the signal the
injection max amount the injection
cooldown the failed time the injection
start the injection amount the track
rate it's all here in plain text so
there is definitely a possibility that
I'm gonna be able to get to every single
bit over this Wi-Fi and it just so
happens when I was trying to hack it
before that I got to the really really
problematic one that was extremely
difficult to hack but this one is not so
bad so I will be getting into this and
we will be getting into this and we will
have lots of fun so we're gonna try this
I'm gonna see what happens you ready I'm
ready
Oh before we get started there is
something very important that I wanted
to talk about that we kind of covered in
the last video but it's very important
to my horn
I want to talk about like button abuse
last time we told you to smash the like
button to destroy the like button to
annihilate the like button and then feel
like that was wrong we're always taking
the extra step to destroy the like
button to hate the like button to
annihilate the like button power and
fists of purity if it's time
why not love them why not show the like
button the love that it shows you I want
us all to take a moment to just gently
kiss that like button
just gently caress that like button give
it a sassy spanking
how about that something a little
lighter when I'm in danger or you think
I'm about to die just give that like
button a little little smooch on the
neck a little a little hickey III only
exist through numbers if numbers are
high then I'm happy and my life has
meaning that's that's what I think about
that like button so death definitely
definitely definitely try that okay
we're gonna get this I've got more and
more tips and tricks I've got more
strategies I've got more stuff to do I
am ready and I am probably gonna die
horribly but I'm ready nonetheless so
let's get into it
I'm probably gonna die but I am
committed to trying this a little bit
harder than I have in the past I think
really certain I'm pretty sure that I'll
be able to do this properly but I'm not
100% certain there's also a little thing
here where um I've got a list of
supposed ports for the WEP password so
maybe I don't even need to scan the
ports if those are all the same I've
never noticed if those were the same
before but maybe they are I'm not a
hundred percent sure but we're gonna try
this okay
let's disconnect and shut her off let's
go get the free beep VPN and let's
boogie Audi come on there we go all
right this is where the game gets real I
need to turn up the volume for you guys
so you can hear all the nuances and you
can get jumpscared just as much as I do
right there we go and now I can hear new
new day new fun new happiness fun times
all around let's do this
and maybe we'll be able to get the
dollmaker event this time around we
haven't had the dollmaker in the first
the first wiki page that we've had in a
long time so and not that I want it but
you know just in case it happens it
would be something interesting and new
that happens that we haven't seen before
but if it does it does if it don't it
don't and maybe it's entirely dependent
on you maybe if you scream at the top of
your lungs we want the doll maker then
the doll maker will be there but I'm not
a represent sure there's also I was
reading up on the doll maker stuff just
because I didn't want to be met with a
complete unknown but there's apparently
you have to hack this downstairs
computer and that's what the Lowell P
disk is for I don't know the rest of it
but all I know is that the the guide
said that you had to do that for that
and then supposedly suppose it wouldn't
be so bad
become the doll I don't know if I want
to become the doll I don't know if
that's an ideal I don't know if that's a
good idea for this you guys have had a
lot of bad ideas throughout this
endeavor but that one might be one of
the worst ones to become the dull you
want the doll maker yes scream it at the
top of your lungs it's more likely to
happen if you type it real hard and if
you really caress soothingly smooch that
like button maybe it'll be more possible
to happen no I don't think you want me
as the doll I don't think that's good I
don't think the doll maker wants me as
the doll I mean I got I got a pretty
nice bod but I don't know if that'd be
entirely good for me also it is a
mechanic in the game where you if you
use your flashlight too much the
flashlight will die so you don't want to
use it nearly at all you only want to
use it when the power goes out I mean I
use it sometimes to see in the dark
corners of my apartment because I play
with the lights out but it's not the
best idea in the world not the best idea
all right la key lock oh wait I'm going
out anyway all right take this la unlock
E lock let's see if there's anything
over here nope no no no I'm watching the
bottom right cymbal more than anything
because that's more reliable than just
checking the walls nope nothing here
nothing here all right there's a yellow
yellow yellow yellow nope let's try
upstairs first whoa yes okay
easy-peasy first one's easy all right
now my objective is not to buy too many
of those things I just want to get one
motion sensor you guys I know we're
screaming at the top of your lungs for
two you got good too but I don't want to
get too I just want one and that's all I
need all right let's go zero day market
let's get online let's go to tp-link now
if Courtney of the guy this free Wi-Fi
is actually one of the best free Wi-Fi
is to get because it allows you to have
the absolute most possible time on it
nearly like 15 minutes on this thing
without being detected and I'm pretty
sure that's just because it's the first
one but as soon as we get the sky break
we're going to get that up and running
I've got
my notepad right here with all my notes
I'm ready to get it I'm gonna get the
motion sensor it's gonna be all great ok
brutal underground that is indeed not
one that's available now but it will be
available burned at the stake know
chosen awake no deep Journal yes it's
available now ok sky break is up and
running I'm gonna try WEP scan I'm gonna
try something kind of cool now so I need
to look at every single letter on this
page I don't think I need to worry about
them just yet
every single letter mmm oh god there's
so many words nothing nothing nothing
nothing no nothing let's get this going
I'm gonna try this first
I I don't know if this is how this is
gonna work 6 and because it says I've
got a list of the supposed ports but I
just want to test if it works first so
crack 8 this one is 6 7 - let's try that
nope ok alright so you do have to probe
it alright let's actually just probe
alright we're gonna probe that first
then we're hopeful the best alright so
this is D D v 9 709 got it ok what do we
got what do we got
nope
alright everybody keep your ears open in
case there's some sounds that I need to
be aware of it makes me swell I think
she saw me looking out her window and
she smiled at me I almost came right
then she's amazing oh yeah great oh
there's a long ass website take them
titties out and go to
mmm beat the [ __ ] out of you man she
does have [ __ ] respect yeah if there's
one thing that's being being thrown
around here it's respect yeah took it
look in the bag in it smells like a box
of her trash
oh that's awful horrible hey I found it
okay BRAC 6 & 9 4 w r 7 l LJ 8 6 4 1
okay
the reason I'm coming through this if
you missed it um it was brought to my
attention that I am stupid and I need to
check every single word every single
letter every single possible thing in
here for clickable that is what gives
the things that you need and if you
don't look at every single little thing
then you are going to be boned forever Z
X C V B and M okay all right let's go
ahead and crack the other one I'm good
on this free password for the moment oh
boy
good God look at all this [ __ ] quick
peek holy [ __ ]
wonderful Congrats mmm that's not good
all right probe FSDB ra and qc9
one to a thousand all right
watching over the past few days trying
to nail down a routine I think she goes
to the mall after masquerade ball four
times a day I hope she misses me about
that keep that [ __ ] rub one out yeah
okay all right anonymous been a while
since I posted thinking killing me
finally saw it finally saw her again boy
hope she's not mad at me yeah women are
puzzles well maybe maybe if you weren't
stalking this one person maybe it
wouldn't be so much of a puzzle you know
just that's just a thought I have but
who what do I know honestly what do I
know
or this is I forget which one this is
but I'll get it later okay man this is
feel like my balls are going to explode
maybe that'd be for the best maybe if
your balls blue
that would be that'd be just kind of the
best thing that could happen at this
juncture [ __ ] Cruella something to do
oh god oh no oh no no no that's that's
not okay that's the opposite okay
alright I don't think anyone's gonna be
here yet not until I find the first key
found this one so s s Wi-Fi is Willy
will II will I okay let's go ahead and
hop on to the first free Wi-Fi that we
got here let's go to Z xev beatin him
I got it cuz this page just not work or
is it is it something else okay we're
gonna hop we're gonna hop the Wi-Fi
pretty much every 10 minutes we don't
need to actually we don't need to
actually worry about Wi-Fi too bad but I
just want to just want to get ya
outwardly angry at me so I snagged her
shoe in a box what sighs looks like
she's a seven it's a seven that's a so
god oh no oh no no no oh boy I haven't
been looking in the source code either
she's gone off the deep end she looks
right at me and tells me to stop staring
at her it hurts so much we have a
connection I don't think she sees it oh
boy oh no oh no no been trying to show
her how much I love her and she's acting
like I'm gonna kill her oh no
uh-uh no oh no that's not huh that's not
hot Oh God
Oh fuming haven't left my apartment want
to wait oh now you want a strangler
maybe her fears were justified maybe
that was a thing wish I could give you a
hug okay no not gonna let her go I have
to see where she's going I'm going after
her good luck gonna be both much I've
loved I need to figure out but I can
stop worrying so much finally finally
get to talk to her
yeah she's starting to see my ways I
think okay she's gonna move in with me
oh no oh oh no oh she's she's dead oh
she's dead oh she's she's dead oh she's
dead she's dead okay all right that's
horrible that's horrible
that's the worst thing I've ever seen
all right do we see a website in here no
I don't think there's gonna be anything
good in here this is just as a venture
in awfulness this is just a journey down
into some horrible horrible miss oh god
also I have so few daus going why do I
have so few daus coin I guess it just
doesn't make as much as you think it
would
boy no thanks
alright anything here I'm gonna guess a
whole lot of nope
I'm guessing this was just a freaking
waste oh this is just a big-ass waste of
my time yep I'm almost on represent sure
didn't need to know any of this didn't
need to know any of this could have
lived my life without knowing about this
okay that was nothing there was nothing
it was a whole lot nothing I combed
through every little scrap of that every
little nuance of that and there was
absolutely dick diddly great I'm gonna
switch Wi-Fi cuz it feel like it
alright ss Wi-Fi we've got Willie great
well how you guys doing huh if that
grossed you out give that like if that
was horrible hmm I'm on it I'm I'm I'm
doing the thing okay on crave let's see
what on crave has probably nothing good
stupid slow Wi-Fi I need to get to wpa2
because wpa2 is the fastest Wi-Fi and
that's that's really what we need do not
break the nine I would never dream of it
let me check the source code first nope
nope okay so let's just check all of
these little pieces of [ __ ] cuz there's
bound to be there's bound to be stuff in
here you just got to be mindful for it
see this is what the game is all about
like the game actually does just kind of
drag and drag and drag just from doing
these things over and over again because
there's just so much like there's just
so much to comb through that's why it'd
probably be for the best to get the key
maybe maybe eventually just I don't know
go for as much money as you can through
the the hack exploit and stuff like that
but I don't know geez this is what I got
to do nope nothing there's nothing but
the end nope okay let's go to the gate
nothing yet
I've got no money because no one's tried
to hack me okay hello lady how you do a
nice eye
the gate is open you have been warned at
the ground is dead under our feet I
don't know if that's true no nothing
okay we got nothing go hold on nothing
we got nothing we got nothing I can
probe five to a thousand I know I can I
know I can but I won't
I just won't do it give me money gimme
fuel gimme fire gimme that which I
desire no all right that's fine I'm
gonna get this one no let's go down come
on so much I hate that one I hate it
it's so stupid it's stupid it's stupid
and I hate it it's stupid it's stupid
and I hate it I hate it and it's stupid
it's stupid and full of poopie and it's
dumb it's dumb and I hate it
[Music]
nope nothing no nothing I don't know if
I have to go through that if I do I'm
gonna be very pissed
nothing bought a bunch of bull poopy
nothing but the poop iasts believe ever
seen just a bunch of poopy dicks oh
let's go for real photos oh boy
can't wait for this yeah all right we
need to switch Wi-Fi pretty soon I guess
we can go back to the free one but once
I get out of this I think I should be
fine for a little bit longer if I'm on
SS Wi-Fi oh no that's not very long
let's let's go ahead and switch back to
the free Wi-Fi
just in case cuz I don't wanna I don't
wanna I don't want to do anything
because I've got a list of the supposed
times for each of these two it's 376
seconds 4 SS Wi-Fi so best to hop around
best to hop around alright nope that's
not good okay that's not good okay not
good not good not good not good not good
not good not good
[Music]
not good not good no not good not good
not good
Oh No wait I see something no nope PDP
block no anything in the purchase no
it's taking way too long
we're making no money we're getting our
money stolen from us no wallet companion
found access denied what about the this
know doesn't my the looks of it okay I'm
gonna scratch that one off list I comb
through it real tight real tight I don't
know okay evil collection that is a
thing yes okay getting nervous now I
don't know why home images links evil
collection why do they do this internet
browsers nobody's else's [ __ ]
business this is my corner the
webosphere some various things I found
there me more stuff public bgp block
updated a while ago images let's go for
it oh I didn't check the source code
again and whatever I'll go back to the
home page eventually okay just my image
is browse more of it I don't see
anything okay creepy let's go creepy I
like creepy pics creepy pics are good
creepy pics are the best or let's hop
Wi-Fi again actually just in case
actually let's go through this one from
no stop a god damn it hot Wi-Fi well
[ __ ] I'm not dead how how would I be
dead I haven't even gotten anything the
windows not even open the police aren't
here the windows not open nothing's
wrong I have no money
chats been taken down guess choose a
color all right no no chat
no links no nothing no nothing chad has
been taken down oh no oh god no why
could it be why could it be how could it
be how could it be all right here we go
mmm mmm that's that's unpleasant that's
that's unpleasant oh that's that's
horrifying oh that's awful
oh that's unpleasant that's unpleasant
that's fine that's not pleasant that's
unpleasant oh there we go that guy I
know that guy anything here nope okay
all right then Oh
let's go links we'll go back to pictures
cuz there's a lot more pictures but just
in case yeah oh god no I know these
horrible creepy pictures all right place
them is around ooh
what the hell what Oh links what what is
baby time baby baby baby baby baby baby
baby baby baby baby baby baby baby baby
baby baby baby baby baby baby baby baby
baby baby baby baby baby baby baby baby
baby baby baby baby baby baby all right
all right okay just baby time
let's go to and book whatever that is
all right I knew I knew I knew I was
just gonna be that all right I don't
know what an book is yeah something
tells me it's not gonna be any better
than Facebook something tells me
something tells me oh god I found
nothing I found a lot of nothing see I
wonder if it'd just be better to try to
get as much daus coin as possible you
know I really do wonder if it's like
that is the best strategy just try to
get as much Dass coin in the beginning
of the game and then go for the key
finder and that way it'll be easier then
you know
when a key is on a page you don't waste
your time because a lot of this game is
just about time management right so I'm
gonna try that I'm gonna try that I'm
actually going to just I'm gonna flip
through these various actually I'm just
gonna screw this I'm going for the next
Wi-Fi SS Wi-Fi is Willie and this is a
good one to stay on just got here no
again dad got it easy well that was easy
and I had a million I had a bunch of
time whatever 3.5 I've got no money I've
got no money
I've got like no money where's all my
money give me my money
that's what I want my money where's my
goddamn money all right whatever I've
got a global cooldown on being hacked so
I'm just gonna is it better just to keep
going oh no no no flame is not one hail
Satan is also not one happy family is
not one hidden pleasures that's one yes
oh this one has so much text ah you know
what I'm just gonna try to get money if
I die this time around because the
threats get too real then that's just
this is what it is but I need the money
oh wait there's something like [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
okay so there must be something there
because suddenly when I went to that
website things got all weird huh
things got a little weird no present
sure but I think things got a little
weird and that website is where there
must be something there right oh yeah oh
yeah there must be something all right
let's do this
go back to there I'm ready show me the
codes give me something good baby baby
baby oh god this so much [ __ ]
IVA VAD or the website was just or the
game was just like okay you've been
[ __ ] around for far too long let's
let's just let's just speed this up here
let's get your death out of the way how
the [ __ ] oh there's so much here there's
so much here is this so much oh my god I
want the key finder okay [ __ ] it there's
something in hidden pleasures but I'm
just I want the key finder I want the
key finder I want to live dangerously
I'm gonna scoot by I wanna I want to
really mess up my day
I want to mess up my steez we're gonna
go too nope not that there easy easy
Peas easy peasy give me the money I've
never had this low money I've never had
this low amount of money when I started
this oh man all right let's go back
there's pretty much the worst start I've
ever had to any of these any of this
type of game so let me know let me move
the Wi-Fi dongle let me just go ahead
and do that because I think you know I
don't I I don't know I think you could
just hop between Wi-Fi of the same
network over and over again but I'm not
100% sure what would be the best way to
go about that you know what I mean
because this one has two free Wi-Fi and
they're relatively safe I think yeah
they're relatively decent it's only got
one of these whatever probe q h q QV h
sy s zs
yeah which one's this one PFW let's try
300 to 800 give me a little better range
but I don't know if that's gonna be the
right one anyway
hop on the Wi-Fi free one and go might
be time to get another hack going on
here all right well that Wi-Fi is slow
oh that Wi-Fi is slow happy family I
might want to run I can't there's
nowhere to run where would I run I can't
run
nope found it alright crack uh q h QV h
sys is yes channel 12
five four three okay this one didn't
work didn't work guys i'm trying to get
hacked i'm trying my damnedest
I'm just they don't want to hack me they
know what Elite hacks or I am did I lock
the door I did okay I'm good they know
what a sweet hacker I am
I did fail the first hack or maybe me
failing the first hack made it so much
easier
the password is dick okay PW f138 is
dick all right good to know
passwords dick I like that that's good
bass we're dick that's a good password
hack me hack me bastards hack me you
bastards hmm I don't know if refreshing
is better than just going backwards and
forwards hack me give me money give me
money not it's got to be just refreshing
is it refreshing or is it going
backwards and forwards I'm not a
Mersenne sure yeah change the Wi-Fi as
much as possible oh yeah don't trust me
that's exactly what I'm doing
all right trying to hard mode get hacked
more yeah I know I'm pretty sure maybe I
don't know Lucas lives in the same
building you know I wouldn't doubt it I
really wouldn't doubt it whoa oh yeah no
that's not what I want that's what
happened last time apparently I wanted
to buy that and I didn't have enough das
coin which is [ __ ] cuz I did and I
have no idea why it said I didn't fail
in the first puzzle I did you have to
fail in the first puzzle but I did but
what is what are you talking about
you're just saying that you're not
saying why what do you mean fail in the
first puzzle I did what are you talking
about hmm oh I see I see what you mean
the ozone wall
okay I've been kind of like intermediate
[Music]
I failed all right okay why I be a jibe
X Y max it's like some horrible Sesame
Street sir - good work sir - good
to a pet tips tip sir give me some sweet
tips on how to play oh that's a lot of
money oh hell yeah that's a lot of money
all right let's buy a motion sensor then
holy [ __ ] look that's a lot of money
there's a lot of money guys guys there's
a lot of mourning guys just a good bit
of money oh yeah all right let's go get
up let's go get that before it's too
late it's 11 o'clock right now 11:30 is
one things get bad out there we're
probably gonna run into the breather
anyway let's go Getti let's go Katy Audi
look do this oh let's do this oh I'm
kind of ready I'm not ready but that's
good advice that's good advice thank you
for that advice that really is great
somebody somebody please clap for that
person or everybody that was giving me
advice like that that's good advice
that's great advice nice the best advice
that I could ever hope for yeah yeah I
know the breathers probably gonna kick
my ass I'm well aware of that fact I
still haven't been able to beat the
breather the the reaction times on that
bad boy is just obscene I'm gonna try my
best but I have no hopes for it I didn't
hear anything
I'm a trust myself I trust my instincts
I trust my instincts I didn't hear [ __ ]
I'm not gonna waste time
[ __ ] you breather I'm a [ __ ] bad-ass
[ __ ] you get the [ __ ] out of here you
think you powerful you think you mean
you ain't mean you nothing you nothing
you're nothing gravy boy huh you ain't
nothing to me you ain't nothing to
nobody
you just try you just try you try you
try buddy yeah you got nothing
yeah he's got nothing on me okay
so we just got yeah yeah yeah yeah I
tried to give you advice almost every
stream it's kind of hard to see this is
the first time I've actually turned
nightbot on and been able to fight the
spam so I'm sorry if I haven't seen this
is like the first stream where I've been
able to actually read stuff so it's good
it's good all right all right let's put
no one's here
let's put this bad boy I thought I ran
into something on the ground there those
weird all right we're gonna put this bad
boy right here in the hallway right here
in the hallway baby oh that's good
that's a good spot right there that is a
good spot I don't have a camera there if
I can never access it you know that's my
question
all right walkies all right we're good
let's do this let's kick some ass let's
kick some ass let's kick some serious
mass all right we're gonna go to TC a 1
which is it not great one but oh well
all right let's get hot again
doot-doot doot-doot and then we're gonna
get emotional eart all right you guys
keep an eye on that hallway motion alert
you guys keep an eye on that you guys
keep an eye you guys keep an eye let's
go flame come on flame hack me do it I'm
here hack me come on now hack me attack
me there's definitely something on that
that that human trafficking website
there's definitely something on that
just got to get there no no no no no no
I'm not gonna get I'm not gonna get
killed no no no I'm not gonna get killed
I bought back doors I've got four back
doors I've got four I've got four back
doors you know what actually I'm gonna
give you something that you want now you
can see my daus coin now you've got it
are you happy now are you happy now
are you happy maybe I should just put my
webcam down hear that dead probably
smart I'm gonna do that for you guys you
know just cuz I like you guys so much
just cuz I like you
I'm gonna do that for you guys you heard
they nerfed Lucas they probably did but
if they did that last week I don't know
what the nerf exactly entails but it was
only a slight nerf I don't have enough
money for a sound alert I will get that
don't worry I will get that don't worry
your pretty little head I will get that
nope not that Blanc that's not for me
that's not for me that's not for me
that's not for me I just hopped on this
free wife and hasn't been enough I'm
willing to bet money that is not for me
not for me
Justin K is gonna flip Wi-Fi anyway
let's go - lets go - dick I guarantee
that is not for me guarantee that is
just random noise please get called all
the time that is not for me
guaranteed guarantee that guarantee not
for me all right here we go
memory zero T Z for easy road easy for
one Q b6 j 1q b6 j el y n HZ Lin no zero
Oh No Oh WD h 0o WD h 0 got it wow
that's a lot of moly moly that's a lot
of money that's a lot of moolah is what
I think I meant to say but I'm not I
wasn't sure you never know with this
stuff all right we've got 98 we've got
98 DOS going we need more we need a lot
more but I can by the WPA let's go
straight w2 PA 2
because I now know what to do about that
and I told you the police were not for
me that was not for me I don't need to
panic at everything [ __ ] I need to panic
all right let's panic damn it's locked
let's go nothing happens god damn it one
of these days I'm gonna be fast that
just happens it happens it happens to
the best of us it happens to me that
doesn't mean it's anything to worry
about
anybody in here hello no all right good
all right let's get out of here let's
get a tea all right so now we've got we
should have police we should have anyway
the did we get what we needed did we get
what we needed yeah we got it we got a
baby we got it okay so now I have a very
very very good list of Wi-Fi information
about this [ __ ] here so with that
being said okay we're going to inject a
0-3 KN e ar e one we need okay which one
is this this is KP n fawn this is the
low one so we can only do five at a time
on Channel seven five and the cooldown
is every four seconds damn it okay the
max was the max was five okay so that
means I needed to do four okay so I'm
gonna switch Wi-Fi I'm gonna move this
Wi-Fi back over here but I'm gonna
connect one of these this is gonna work
you're gonna see you're gonna see okay
scan we're scanning it's gonna work it's
gonna work
you need to keep refreshing on this oh I
need to connect something refresh oh
there's so many WPA twos okay
let's go okay ethical hacker that's a
decent one what about maxium black
that's a decent one snuffbox that's
nutty someone yeah that's a good one
let's go let's go that one okay let's do
inject g29 vy9
why b16 inject on channel one
let's it says let's do 50 BAM okay cool
let's keep going on this woo who's gonna
work
okay the cool down on that is 12 seconds
so we need to wait 12 seconds every time
before we're able to do that again let's
buy a motion sensor alert - let's go
again yeah this is gonna work this is
gonna work 1 2 3 4
no not a [ __ ] I bought a motion sensor
not emotional eart god dammit god dammit
dammit now I have another dammit great
great
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I want to get
hacked again before I get down there
well that's probably not a good idea if
I'm just gonna guarantee the breathers
gonna be down there isn't it
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh it's offline - I didn't wait 12
seconds well whatever let's just get off
of this thing
no let's disconnect from that thing
alright let's go get that motion alert
because we have it so we might as well
go get it right damn it oh wow such a
piece of garbage
such a piece of Garbo i'ma die to the
breather now I I it's just I am I'm
gonna die to the breather like it's
guaranteed that I'm gonna die because
I'm gonna get the breather not only am I
gonna get the breather but I'm gonna die
to the breather
we're so boned we're boned we're boned
if we're boned if you think we're boned
just hover over that like button and
just the gentlest little love tap on
that like button just oh sweet sweet
like but if you know that I'm boned -
the breather which I am I've yet I'm
seriously I've yet to be able to beat
the breather and I know that it's gonna
be the death of me I didn't want to go
out here again didn't hear anything
didn't hear dick didn't your dick get
[ __ ] breathable yeah yeah it chode
breathe man
it showed breathe man ha ha ha ha ha
victory is mine now I have 2 motion
alerts what fat lock good that is gonna
do me it's gonna do me absolutely dick
diddly but hey no no no no I know how to
beat the brave yeah I know how that
doesn't mean I can do it the reaction
times it's cuz it's so dark in there I
can't actually see the door when the
door handle starts to move is like
really really really really quick
reaction times and I'm not and I used to
it enough I haven't
practice you know what I mean yeah you
know what I mean all right all right
let's go for it we're fine we're fine
suprisingly we're fine surprisingly
anybody in here hello okay all right
grab this let's put this in the
stairwell and then we'll have to motion
alerts don't know what good that's gonna
do me but we're gonna put in the
stairwell okay we got that I don't think
it even matters where you put it in the
stairwell because I think the game just
registers there's movement in the
stairwell there's a character in the
stairwell I would love to see like a
five nights at Freddy's 4 style map for
it lock all right let's try this again
we were let's try I think it's the same
one is still there yeah we can just try
that again all right and we're actually
gonna wait the proper amount of time
this time let's go to D this one nope
come on
all right cool I'm just I'm still just
trying to get hacked I just want money
I'm so greedy
I just want money heard something I
don't think it was anything though
nope I'm pretty fortunate no one's been
after me but I know my luck is gonna
change pretty soon anyway
how to Lucas good question honestly I
don't know have one two three oh oh hey
buddy
hi well I just had to say something
didn't I I just had to say something I
just had to say something well you know
that's just the way it goes sometimes
sometimes you get good sometimes you get
boned but you still there okay he's gone
okay let's do it again
can you please hack me I need lots of
[Music]
how the freaky no there we go oh my
goodness gravy yes please and there and
okay screw you buddy
screw you buddy screw you screw you
buddy screw you Oh screw you buddy screw
you screw you buddy
screw you oh boy screw you buddy oh man
I'm getting better at that though
surprisingly I am getting better at that
all my complaining about it finally paid
off
oh no motion alerts no motion alerts we
got nothing let's buy an audio there we
go audio motion alert it's installing
baby we're gonna be safe ish we're gonna
we're gonna be safe right this is what
safety means right probably okay this
one needs about six hundred and forty
two to get in there but once we get in
there it's gonna be a fast lovely Wi-Fi
it's gonna be fast it's gonna be
beautiful
and it's gonna be nice all right all
right let's get another backdoor hack
almost got the motion alert it is now
officially 11:30 I think Lucas should
probably be coming around the corner
pretty soon here somewhere around here
Lucas is around here somewhere no no
okay I own a motion alert I own a motion
alert I own inaudible motion alert
inaudible motion alert I have that I own
it I bought it with my money that are
technically I think I stole from people
but I bought it anyway I have that
that's mine that is mine all right after
this I'm gonna hop over the different
Wi-Fi I'm pretty close to getting this
pretty close anyway Oh scoop alright
let's hop over a different Wi-Fi let's
go back to the free working on hacks
working on hacks just working on hacks
right now thought I heard something
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
know okay there it is oh jeez
god damn it every time every time every
time for sure okay I'm good at the stack
butcher that's a good amount of money
that's good money right there that's
good money okay it's gonna be another 70
seconds before I can get the next one
motion alerts still are fine haven't
heard anything I'm assuming I'm gonna
heard you're something I'm assuming
assume I hear something okay I need to
wait 12 seconds in between these it's my
be it this might get me there oh there
we go okay crack g29 vy9 yb9 6 and
channel is 1 okay we're cracking that
let's go ahead and change Wi-Fi this is
Oh Tucker
all right so snuffbox snuff is Tucker
let's go ahead and connect to that one I
don't want to wait around there it is
okay Tucker got it all right let's scan
we should be good on that one for a good
at least like 30 minutes at least 30
minutes right at least 30 minutes okay
so let's keep going we should be able to
get hacked pretty soon why did you order
this water that's a good one yeah let's
do that one yeah channel 7 and it says
65 is what we can do that's work if you
guys hearing weird you guys hearing
weird sounds you guys hearing weird
sounds I think you're hearing weird
sounds I'm hearing weird sounds okay the
cooldown is six seconds in between that
so that's that's really good okay oh
that's fast
oh that's speedy baby oh that speedy
baby haw that speedy alright yeah oh
yeah this one's gonna be easy to hack
this is gonna be real easy so speedy on
that so speedy
[Music]
don't break me yeah no oh my god okay
flying [ __ ] come on
okay I think I got it amazingly I think
I got it gave me almost too much time
for that it's getting really hard these
puzzles are getting way tough 103 103
that's so much money I've got 237 I need
375 to be able to get this NE 375 more
backdoor hacks alright we're gonna go we
probably need one more backdoor hack
maybe two to be able to do this so then
once we have that we should be able to
avoid intentionally triggering hacks and
then we should be good to go still
nothing on the motion alerts boy that
was fast that wasn't a 70 second
cooldown
was it got it that was easy
at least I went over a relatively linear
path I don't know if these [ __ ] can
come get me when I'm being hacked that
is something that I don't know I'm not a
hundred percent fast I'm not 100 percent
sure about that okay whoa 153 that might
yes that's enough okay that's enough we
can buy the key q okay we're buying the
key Q we're hacking into this thing
we've got a long way to go on this
Wi-Fi but so far so good so far so good
I think that's all we need to do for
that so we can go into these other
websites as soon as we get the key key
which is gonna take [ __ ] forever
apparently okay all right all right I'm
getting more and more nervous just
because now I'm getting to the point
where I actually have steaks here I've
gotten to where I need to go and I've
got the key queue on the way and that
should be like the last thing that you
need to do besides just focusing on
getting those Wi-Fi is in order once I
have these two Wi-Fi I should be able to
just flop between these wi-fi's and I
should be okay
not on represent sure but should be okay
yeah
I've just hazarded
okay I think we're fine I'm not I heard
a footstep is what I heard I thought I
heard a footstep but I don't know what
that was I didn't see any motion alert I
didn't hear a motion alert go off and
then the power went off which was super
weird oh god yeah which was super weird
so I'm not a hundred percent sure what
the [ __ ] just happened luck I really I'm
really uncertain as to what just
happened okay I'm just gonna hop to it
or actually I'm pretty close to this
Wi-Fi probably I just need to I don't
know man I really don't know I honestly
I have no idea what happened okay where
am I
jeez I really don't know what happened
there
I'm just confused more than anything
Lucas can come from both sides of the
hallway I mean it doesn't say it just
says floor 8 hallways so I think it
doesn't matter where you put it I'm
pretty sure anyway no not no no no not
skin [ __ ] you okay okay it kept the
progress okay good good good good good
good good good good good okay
kept the progress totally fine mmm I
thought that was gonna be bad for a
second there so that was gonna be bad
okay did we get the key thing installed
okay key Q is owned let's go to hidden
pleasures and let's see what the key Q
is gonna say doesn't see you Q didn't do
anything
does that mean there's nothing here or
does that mean it's just not in this
surface web page okay that's nothing
does it give an audio cue notify them
the right of a NN if there's a key on
this website okay well I don't see
anything so it must not be here right if
it doesn't say it's on the website then
it must not be there right that's my
thought process don't know if that's
sure okay I am here yeah no it's not
available right now okay that's fine
keepsake should be worn okay bottom
right oh there's a key on this website
okay there is a key
okay
oh there it is
what the [ __ ] was that what was that
sound like a breath but I don't know of
the breather ever coming up here so I
don't think that was anything I don't
think that was anything just my paranoia
god damn it oh there's a key here but I
don't remember where [ __ ] I'm getting so
paranoid I'm getting unbelievably
paranoid right now I'm getting like a
ridiculously paranoid I don't know that
one honk one honk not two honks one honk
did my okay I have the motion blur
where would it be
goddamn it's on here where is it oh my
god
money one money one money one where's my
god where's my Oh where's my pen where's
my pen oh [ __ ] where's my pen where the
[ __ ] is my pen where my pen go weird
where the [ __ ] is my pen well where the
[ __ ] did my pen just go where's my
pannier where the [ __ ] did that go what
the [ __ ]
there it is Jesus Christ Oh getting
super paranoid okay I can't lose my cool
okay this is why did why did is money
one let's just go over to money one why
did let's go to money was the closest
one I've had uh yeah okay I don't need
any more anything really um there was
nothing there
yeah wait no sorry I've totally
flustered I have no idea what I'm doing
remind me to change Wi-Fi in there what
the hell what I tried to click on that a
million times
okay three nine three zero B 7 6 3 D
- f5 okay alright that's one that's the
first one that's good now that doesn't
mean that that was the first one we've
encountered I'm gonna go back to the
other websites that I've been to already
and I'm gonna just look at him just in
case just in case okay anything here no
there's nothing on this website I was
right about this one I did comb through
these pretty thoroughly
okay let's try on crave anything on this
website no nothing okay good I wasn't
wrong about this one wasn't wrong about
that one uh evidence Locker nope nothing
on this website
nope nothing on this white I wasn't
wrong about that that's good that's good
I just changed wife I literally just did
a evil collection nothing on this
website good okay so this means that was
the first one that we've encountered so
far I am here should be available right
now nothing on this website okay but
maybe wait hang on let me go back to
that maybe there's something in the
source code I do have to look at the
source code still just because I need to
look for the one for the second wiki
nothing okay good
man that would be a pain in the ass to
look for something there our Legion not
one
Legion is not not one little front
nothing little friends no not now
milk supply that's one right I think
that's one okay there's no key here let
me check the source code
this is the best progress I've had so
far so even if I don't make it on this
one I will be pretty proud of myself
because I I've gotten pretty far pretty
far on this gun pretty far
alright umm mutilation I think that's
yeah that's definitely one that's like
the twitch website for mutilation but
there's nothing on this page no until I
until I'm gonna get through everything
first I'm not gonna dive deep into these
websites looking for the the second wiki
page until I find that all the keys on
this passports are Russ that is not one
roses destruction that's not one share
your genitals three l8e cx-3 l8 ECX oh
no zero a two V L C Z zero a 2l oh [ __ ]
me are W X K s J 1 RW x k SJ 1 oh my god
f a J or X E
one F AJR XE 1 3 4 H X I Y 3 4 H X I Y
oh oh okay all right
144 darn that does nothing for me I have
so much money now why do I have so much
money I've got so much money and nothing
to spend it on I'm not going outside
that's just I'm not doing it
ok share your genitals think that's one
huh alright nothing on this one anything
in the source code come on just oh Jesus
hate that no nothing there
oh hello hi okay
[Music]
changing Wi-Fi just in case I don't
think I need to but I'm doing it anyway
going back to Tucker home
I should probably I should probably scan
one more of these just in case just in
case because I don't want to be left out
in the lurch with not the right ones
let's come on let's go we need to go
okay
tango Down that is not one fan of two
notes that is one but not available now
eights in not one the dollmaker no I
don't want to I don't want to go with
the dollmaker
I don't want to do that I really just I
don't want to go the dole makers website
okay there's nothing here it says I just
don't want I just don't want to do it
right I don't want to handle something
I've got a potential to win something
and I'm like man I don't want to I don't
do the let's do maxium black max okay
oh we're gonna inject nah no a FG a ICQ
yjk channel one we're going 25 this one
shouldn't be much effort at all the
cooldown is 10 seconds okay ah I know I
don't want to go to the dollmaker I
don't I will die he'll kill me I don't
know I don't know how to deal with it
I just don't know Brunel on the ground
where is that one um can I go to that
one yet I'm gonna buy I'm gonna buy the
VPN levels things I just don't wanna get
hacked as much I know I just don't want
to do it okay I can't go there yet
I'm so nervous I'm so unbelievably
nervous so unbelievably nervous chosen
awake that's not one flame that was not
one he'll Satan not one happy family not
one hidden pleasures not one but which
one of the the question is which one of
these has the the it's got to be fanat
knows for brutal underground wait I
don't want to go to the dollmaker I
don't want to do the dollmaker I don't I
don't want to do it I'm not gonna do it
you can't make me do it you can't it's
impossible if you want me to do it
slightly tickle that like button
just mash it I don't care anymore
I'm so scared I'm just scared because I
don't want to lose I don't want to lose
what I've made so far I've made so much
progress I've made so much progress I
meant so much progress
[Music]
no I thought I could get that out of my
face get out of my face I don't want you
here I'm not gonna do it I'm not gonna
go the dole makers website I'm not gonna
go I'm not gonna go I'm just not gonna
do it I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it I
don't want to do it I'll feel like doing
it oh you can't make me
you can't make me like I've got I don't
even know how to explain my emotions
right now I don't think I can I don't
think it's possible for me to explain
how I feel it just feels so unbelievable
I don't care
not now if it was like some other time
I'd be like okay yeah I could do that
because what's the risk but now I
actually have a chance to win this I
honestly truly have a chance to win it
I'm like oh man it would be really cool
if I won you know it'd be really cool if
I won boy howdy it'd be really cool if I
won you know it'd be it'd be super all
right if I won I'm very close to the
next area or the next website that's
available at the time for it it's just
one of those time-limited things 99%
hack resistance that's what I'm looking
for
come on come on come on they said it was
gonna be quicker than this
come on he said he was gonna be quicker
than this no no no no no no it's not
happening you're not gonna make it
happen it's not gonna happen I'm not
gonna let it happen there's no way it's
gonna happen
there's no [ __ ] way there's no
absolutely no way no way and your life
okay it's almost time I just need two
more minutes just two more minutes
and I can get to the next website and
then it's gonna be another 15 minutes
until I get made the next one but I'm
not I'm not going outside I'm not buying
anything else I'm gonna just stay right
here stay right here
okay oh my god
well let me make sure it's LA I'm not
gonna peep I'm just gonna make sure okay
it is locked not gonna look through that
hole no motion alert so something went
wrong there whoo-hoo-hoo okay um we need
to get on to some Wi-Fi I don't know
let's just go home I don't know what
that was about but we can go to brutal
underground now Oh No
okay there's no key on this website but
there might be something else we didn't
get a motion alert we didn't get a
motion alert he came from the elevator
but the elevator doesn't work but guys
the elevator wait what am i doing I need
to look in this not that oh yeah yeah
okay
I'm so so riled up I'm so unbelievably
riled up right now
okay um I don't think there's anything
here click here to get access oh I'm not
okay not okay
that's not website that's nothing oh not
okay this one's taking longer to get to
I don't know why this one's taking
longer but it's taking longer didn't
hear footstep I just heard one footstep
that was the only warning I had for
Lucas was one footstep just one plunk
okay I can crack this bad boy channel
one oh my god just one step Estep one
footsies is all we got as a warning for
that one I need the blue whisper what is
that oh I guess I guess but I I'm not
getting that I I'm not going outside I'm
not risking an encounter with the
breather I'm just not doing it like this
should be able to hear it okay maxxium
is Robert let's go ahead and go over to
that one now we've got three to flip
through on here that should be good
enough for us oh my god a load of
[ __ ] load of [ __ ] biggest load
of [ __ ] I've ever seen in my life
alright we're over on the new Wi-Fi
let's go home we can almost go to that
other website fan app knows that might
have the other wiki I'm actually almost
positive that'll have the other wiki
page okay we should be good on cracks
just in case you know you don't know
I'll keep it up and running all right
everybody just hush down I'm gonna I'm
just gonna quietly listen for a while
Lucas gonna use the elevator I get that
but
do 75 really I don't believe that
okay let's go as the NAD knows oh well
there's a key all right well that's our
key
[Music]
okay is there a shut up shut up shut up
shut up I don't like you okay so we got
our second key that's good I don't know
if anybody heard that but we don't have
the wiki page so my guess is I'm a
master this is like nailing blue circles
in for night I got it I'm a master that
okay so I know I need the I know I need
that disc I know I need that but I don't
I could afford both you know what let's
order those I don't want to Rosie's
destruction that was not one tango down
was not one ate sand Legion know that no
I know I'm buying it but I'm so [ __ ]
so [ __ ]
I'm so [ __ ] I'm so [ __ ] I know I
know I know I'm not gonna go there until
I need to I must have missed I must have
missed it's somewhere here I just got to
go it's gotta be here that's not it
that's not it it's gotta be somewhere
here maybe on oh one of the deeper web
sites of this one wait I didn't go
through all these that's right
wait okay gallery that's something no no
contact me
yeah I don't think I've I don't think
I've been through this entire knits
entirety
damn I thought it was gonna be easy
apparently not
god damn it of course okay I didn't see
it here there's no key here either maybe
there was a baby there was a website in
hidden pleasures that I didn't quite go
to maybe if I go to one of the deeper
pages it might be here somewhere
so I'm so not okay hi okay let me lock
my door please just locking my door okay
I might change Wi-Fi um well what am I
on I'm not even on anything I don't
remember what I was on before so I guess
I'll go - why did I order this water you
know what actually I've been to those
I'm gonna go to one of these old free
ones I'm gonna go to this one
you know what no I'm not gonna do that
I'm gonna go to the original cuz [ __ ]
that [ __ ] I was scared
I'm gonna have to go to the doll maker's
website it's it's just like it's forcing
me to I know it is no well there it is
there it is there it is found it found
it found it found it found it found it
that must be why the window opened when
I came to this website if there wasn't a
key on it you bet your ass there was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you dollmaker [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you dollmaker [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
dollmaker [ __ ] off you [ __ ] oh no
that's not it
sorry that's a that's a woman that's not
a website oh I thought I don't know why
did I didn't see oh god damn it I
thought nope I was mistaken I was
mistaken everybody I was mistaken that
was not it I thought I thought
I thought that was it I thought that's
not it okay
I don't want to go get it
I don't want to go get it I don't I'm
gonna die to the breather I'm gonna die
to the breather
there must be something on that website
I don't want to go get my items I don't
wanna I don't want to go get him
I just don't I don't want to go get him
I I don't I don't
it's a can't be here it's not gonna be
here nope I don't know it's gonna be on
the website
[ __ ] all right considering I don't think
I have any choice in the matter I guess
I have to go get the things so let's go
ahead and do that
does a hunk I don't like that
yeah there is yep there [ __ ] is yep
there he is
I've never focused on anything more
intensely than I focused on that I think
he's gone I'm just waiting a little
extra time just in case
let's go I think he's gone just go ahead
and go forth all right
[ __ ] I've never concentrated on anything
more than I concentrated on that now so
if if it turns out I just went through
that [ __ ] to then be killed by Lucas
when I get back up I'm going to be so
unbelievably pissed I'm just gonna be oh
my god I am gonna be so pissed if Lucas
is there when I get back up there I'm
going to lose my mother loving mind I'm
going to lose my [ __ ] if Lucas is up
here if he is okay where is it where
does it go where where where would it be
where would that be the lo P disk do I
just have it now is it just something I
have well there it is okay
well I have that lock the door where's
the blue whisper is it just in my ear
now where's the blue whisper
I don't know where the blue whisper
would be but but nope okay make sure
it's locked
definitely locked okay
okay so some of your saying that the
blue whisper wasn't there which might be
true if I check the shipping but I'm not
going back for it I'm not no way in hell
am I going back for that thing if it's
not there then it's not there but I have
the low P disk which means that I can
act god damn it I I just run that okay
whatever but I have I have the I have
the low P disk which means that I can do
the dollmaker quests so I'm going to the
dollmaker don't like it nothing here
whoa boy all right
please have if you don't have the second
wiki page oh no I didn't need to go here
it's not here
I must have missed it I didn't need to
do this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I thought I heard footsteps - but I I
did everything right
I did everything right I did everything
right I did everything right
[Music]
I need everything right I thought I did
everything right I thought I did
everything right
and in a lot of ways I did but you know
sometimes sometimes life just likes to
get in the way life just likes to get in
the way life just likes to bend you over
the barrel and get in the way
life just likes to get I I don't know
why I cuz I was so caught up in the fact
that like I was so caught up in the fact
that there wasn't something on the doll
makers website that I was like oh no and
then I didn't check it it's like huh
of course it's like of course of course
of course yes I'm gonna keep playing you
know what I'm not gonna do I'm not gonna
do that I'm not gonna do the force hack
thing I'm not gonna do it I'm just gonna
you know I'm just gonna we're just gonna
do this okay we're going for it no we're
gonna disconnect from this Wi-Fi first
get off of there oh my god yeah I know
come on oh jeez I'm just peeved I'm just
sad I'm just sad I'm sad I'm sad I'm sad
I'm sad so I'm guessing that the
dollmaker must be completely optional
they would not hide a key on the
dollmaker they would not force you to
activate that would they but then again
I'm saying these same things about these
game developers that make this game
that's kind of completely [ __ ] so if
you think that that was [ __ ] it
wasn't [ __ ] I know it wasn't
[ __ ] but if you think it was
[ __ ] why don't you give that like
button just stuff just give this sweet
smooch just give a sweet smooch just a
little tender on that like bud and
that's what really really I mean come on
guys
when's the last time you gave that like
button some real love
come on guys wait if I if I don't look
yeah
[Music]
if you don't click on the market and I
[Laughter]
didn't get my free VPN so I wasted my
time
you gotta click on this and then he
calls you in that so when you do that
all right
disconnect we're going again guys we're
going again here we go with meteor to
get this okay we don't want to leave
without a flinch okay off we go fun
playing this game we're gonna have a
problem with it are we no no come on now
give me my magical device there you are
haha boy yes special delivery
here we go alright I'm good I just
needed to get that out of my system I
just needed to get that out of my system
I don't even know why I bother going for
this thing it's not like I need it
whatever it's totally fine
it's 100 percent fine just like
everything in life not a problem
I'm gonna play this game super legit now
I'll play it super legit I'm only gonna
be looking for the second wiki key by
the way I'm gonna start this off by only
looking for the second one yeah I'm not
gonna worry about keys and let's there
straight in front of my eyes but not
gonna worry about any of that let's lock
the door all right and turn on this and
we're good all right let's good and this
one just cuz I feel like it that easy
peasy hop on the Wi-Fi get this going
zero day market shadow market and hop on
the Wi-Fi and we're good sky break and
backdoor hack we are good do you go
let's roll oh wait no we're not good to
go because I forgot to place the damn
thing
it's not even worth placing it's not
even worth it's not worth placing it's
legitimately this is not worth placing
this is not worth wasting my time
running around trying to find this place
please fine well it's funny you guys
you guys are funny you guys are real
funny okay it's like it's like it's like
when you're on a road trip and you only
have so many songs to listen to while
you're out there you know the lock jokes
get real dull they get old and then they
circle back around it like suddenly I
remember why I like these and what makes
me laugh is lock my peewee okay alright
okay lock my mind it's too late my mind
is out my mind is outie my mind has left
my mind is gone but thankfully
thankfully very thankfully I actually do
have all the tools necessary with which
to beat this game this is gonna be a
dick isn't it it's gonna it's gonna it's
gonna make me hunt for the green spot
isn't it no it's gonna make me hunt for
it oh it's gonna make me hunt for it
of course it is but it doesn't matter
like this this early phase anyway the
first 20 minutes like nothing can be
done anyway so why even bother
I mean why even bother it's it's just
gonna be like it's just gonna be waiting
around the first 20 minutes no matter
what I do so I want him I want to try to
go to the websites that I can't access
otherwise I wasn't looking so probably
missed it but that's gonna be nothing
yellow yellow yellow yellow
anything hmm well this is unfortunate
this is really unfortunate you know I
said it wouldn't matter but now I'm like
this is trying to mess with me
yellow yellow yellow yellow Wow okay
okay all right I guess we're still going
down oh there we go
whoop not there come on right I just saw
it it was what
what okay this dam is broken this game
is broken this game is just broken we're
all playing a broken game we're all
praying a broken game to play in a game
that wants to waste your time it just
wants to waste your time it just wants
to waste your time whatever [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you you know what [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
alright let's do this we're doing it
we're gonna do this it's gonna be
awesome and we're gonna make it
we're gonna do this right and it's gonna
be awesome we don't need that big of a
website we need just dis much right
there alright get these in order or get
this up alright let's go
wet let's scan let's start the adventure
okay never mind need to connect to a
Wi-Fi don't I I get if you back to our
hacks alright let's probe into Akzo TPB
3 ft 1 mm please why am I not connecting
to the homepage i lamina hurry up please
hurry hurry hurry hurry
alright Chozen awake let's look for is I
am here here no how about Barra my
daughter deep Journal no don't waste it
no you there is you there there ok so
this is a there's gonna be an
interesting one so we don't have
anything that's accessible from the very
beginning ok but that's good that way we
won't miss any ok let's go from the top
chose it away this should be one are you
woke I'm as woke as I can be breath d5 9
no.9 gonna be and then also get that
says Wi-Fi while I'm here nope why is
that not chosen awoke oh I didn't check
the other one oh no god I'm stupid
that's that's not one I'm dumb all right
okay let's hope we get haxed let's hope
we get a Dido is not one drone spy that
is definitely one I know that is one
alright we're gonna look we're gonna
comb we're gonna comb through these aha
crack a kzl TPB 3fd on Channel eight 701
please all right we're gonna comb
through this bad boy I'm just looking
for the second wiki code that's all I'm
looking for right now like I know there
could be something in here worth
clicking on but I don't see any password
is hello okay password is hello let's go
scan once I get to this let me let me
just finish looking through this website
okay wallet that's a wallet s t90 boots
Rex I hate that I why why why why is it
like that wallet code
no I don't see I don't see anything
god I hate the way this works like this
game is the windows don't work if I
click on this I want it to be on top of
this but it doesn't work that's the
weirdest thing about this it just
doesn't work get cracked st 9z ru u TR x
channel 894 alright let's go ahead and
actually one more one more thing let's
go spy for me
lock the door did i not lock the door
did I not do that did I not do that I
did I did do that you guys are crazy
okay
drones bye nothing here on here source
code no that's an email that is not
there okay so we got this Harley alright
let's go to as soon as we get back home
alright let's go to this one this one is
hello connect refresh I guess we can get
out of this now all right perfect
alright family drug shop that's not one
to forgive me that is one I know that's
one coming up on 30 minutes
obviously in 57 not their numbers
station not their your data I don't
think that was there either brutal
underground the red triangle alright
nothing there forgive me secretly submit
your confession my confession is any
minute now
No
no no no [ __ ] I call BS on that's
too early it's too early
there's no way [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you and [ __ ] that that's I you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you want it you
were gonna try to mess with me ain't no
freakin way
ain't no flip-flapping way it's a big ol
no.2 you know they don't know not doing
that hmm um nothing here I'm still
playing this stupid game submit how
about my colon can you cleanse my colon
for me that'd be that'd be real nice
gonna be really nice the motion alerts
did nothing for me by the way the motion
alerts did absolutely nothing why did
they do absolutely nothing okay it's
almost 30 I need brutal on the ground or
red triangle red triangle is here so
I'll go to that as soon as I can hack as
fryer is no happy family no heirloom
that is one it's not a fun one but it is
one
as anything
PGP key having been hacked yet but it's
getting close to time anything here in
the PGP key
no not that I can see anyway I'm gonna
expand this is made a little easier to
read I said I'm gonna expand this make
it a little easier to read nope yeah I
don't see I think quality I didn't go
all the way through the homepage and
whatever it doesn't matter
Oh God
ah the worse the worst ah oh god it's
the worst
that's the worst I gotta go back to the
homepage ah you got the you got the
motion sensors and it didn't work
because you're being haunted by ghosts
you know I might actually believe that I
would actually believe that i 100%
believe that actually
nothing they're containers I can't see
anything here that would didn't seem to
be anything clickable on that page
haven't been hacked yet I want to be
hacked give me money give me money give
me money give me money now give me money
now that's what's appreciated I need to
get to a different Wi-Fi soon no nope
nothing here no that's an email I gotta
go through the homepage once I'm done
with this I'll flip Wi-Fi basically like
at the end of every website that I get
to I'll flip Wi-Fi that seems like a
safe bet alright I just gotta get
through here then get to the bye screen
no Oh how's the body thing alright let's
go to the bye and then that's the last
one I think I know why why does this why
why just why just that's all I want to
know is why is awful oh why are the
people in the why the people who made
this game have to do this oh why Aurora
was that one was that the one d5 nine
yeah okay that's right I forgot
D 955 nine 709 has the shortest window
of time I forgot d5 nine 709 only as a
window of ten minutes I forgot yeah I
only I only flip to that Wi-Fi ten
minutes ago but D D five nine seven oh
nine only as a window of five minutes it
is the shortest window of any Wi-Fi I
forgot to look at my Wi-Fi Chi Chi I
forgot to look I forgot to look you know
what I'm not even gonna bother getting
the weps because they're all [ __ ]
I'm not even gonna bother all I'm gonna
do is I'm just gonna I'm gonna force
hacks I'm not even gonna go get no I
have to cuz otherwise is there a single
thing that I need to is there a single
thing that I need to purchase I don't
think so oh [ __ ] off is there a single
thing that I need to purchase like
honestly is there the VPNs don't do [ __ ]
for me and I mean he's gonna give me
this garbage no matter what I do like is
there a single reason that I would need
to do that I don't think so let me try
this up here maybe that'd be better for
you guys you're I like that and then
we'll get the source code viewer right
like actually will do the source code
viewer right up big right here we'll do
these down here we're gonna do this real
nice slack we're gonna do this real nice
we're just gonna bounce around on the
free Wi-Fi until we can get something we
need okay I guess we can't expand this
why
okay sure yeah that's good enough okay
alright I am here is that here no it's
not borrow my daughter that's here deep
Journal that's here as well don't waste
it is not here you there that's not here
either lol okay so we need to go to
borrow my daughter first I'm just just
upset actually no let's just force some
goddamn let's just force some goddamn
coins I don't even know if we can force
it this early can we force it this early
probably not probably not hey let's see
I mean there's no other way to test it
no other no other no other way to test
it no other way right there's no way to
test it right so this is let's just go
and we'll see if we can force hack will
change Wi-Fi in ten minutes it'll be
great
I'll have a good time it'll be super
chill way fresh it'll be hipping and
happening
it'll be like yo yo yo we'll have lots
of fun it'll be great it's gonna be
great I don't think you can force it
this early I'm pretty sure you can't
force it maybe I don't know
maybe I guess I need to buy this anyway
no matter what sorry I mean I'm grumbled
I know I'm grumbled I know I didn't lock
my door that's right I don't even want
to go get the [ __ ] but if I don't
get hacked in the next like five minutes
I'm gonna I'm just gonna assume that I
can't get hacked until ten twenty
because I've heard that ten twenty is
the first time that you can start
getting hacked and if that's the only
thing then that's the only thing
yeah you can't start getting act until
10:20 okay that makes sense all right I
I believe that I believe that I believe
that so let's just go get the thing
let's go put the thing where it needs to
go
oh let's grab the flashlight actually I
don't think we'll need it but you never
know
this is dude thing let's start this over
whole style we don't go to D 5 9 709
we'll do this normally well this is like
like the way I should do it I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna be an [ __ ] about
this I'm gonna do this way I should do
it I'm gonna approach it logically and
we're gonna be good maybe maybe maybe
maybe maybe maybe yeah change your
internet now I'm not in my computer room
you're behind a little bit buy a new
lock that one's a dud yeah no one is a
dud let's do this [ __ ] this game once
you understand the mechanics it's just
like playing like any other game
especially when it comes to like these
scary games it seems intimidating it
seems daunting but once you break down
the mechanics of it you can get through
it
with no problem like I've beaten the
mechanics of a lot of these things I
know how to do this it takes a lot of
focus and concentration a lot of
understanding but it can be beat and I
will beat it it can be beaten then I
will beat it it can be beaten and I will
beat it
it can be being then I will beat it
everyone just believe that it can be
beaten and I will beat it it can be
beaten and I will beat it but I am gonna
force acts cuz I don't care if it gets
harder I know that the enemies are gonna
come after you sooner but to be
perfectly honest I don't really care
about that because so long as I'm
listening and I'm checking they
shouldn't be able to get me because with
the police being the like the threat of
just changing Wi-Fi that's not a hard
thing to counter and then everything
else is just a matter of listening and
looking and that's it then the game is
won because once you have that underway
the game is won right
there's really nothing else to it okay I
can beat you I can beat you you damned
game yeah cuz now we've officially
discerned that the motion alert is
complete Garbo and absolutely
unnecessary and nobody wants it anyway
all right what do we got do I even want
to put this in any green do I want to
waste time putting this in green spot
why not got a lot of yellow yellow
yellow yellow
red okay we're gonna be jokesters are we
we're gonna be jokesters we're not gonna
give me anything oh we're gonna be a big
little sack of poopy are we okay all
right then we're gonna have nothing
yellow there's yellow yellow yellow and
nothing else okay yellow yellow Carol I
do need to touch it to the wall to
really get a better inclination because
this wasn't yellow on the way up so I
guess I do need to touch it to the wall
yep I'm I'll be left chasin yellow
yellow yellow yellow yellow yellow
yellow yellow yellow yellow yellow
yellow yellow yellow yellow yellow
yellow yellow red red red nice red red
red all green okay all right why so
serious this game this game you guys see
how this game is but we're gonna get
this it's the last thing I do if it's
the last thing I do
we're gonna get this all right so we're
gonna change Wi-Fi cuz I don't even care
we're gonna go over there hop on the
freebie we're gonna go here we're gonna
open up the code breaker we're gonna put
the code breaker it down there right
down here and then this back up here and
then we're good to go
let's go weapon let's scan and let's
start this train are rolling still not
early enough to be hacked so might as
well go somewhere else all right
probe Y 575 JK ba 1s1
all right um it's still 16 so I can
still go to deep journal I want to go to
that before the time gets out the deep
journal and
that's it okay deep Journal oh it's the
stalker thread okay that's not good
oh my windows open already
Oh fascinating
oh hello welcome welcome welcome all
right deep Journal let's look for this
first I really just want to look for see
if I can find the next area I don't know
if it like spawns in specific places or
certain websites I just want to do that
I can always come back for a code later
I seriously can always come back for a
code later but I'm not gonna go for that
now page 2 I'm gonna change Wi-Fi in
like super short time all right source
code OOP back
why 575 JK ba 1s channel 12 602 all
right this is I don't know what this is
pwf yeah pwf there's a p WF p WF has a
about a six minute changeover or ten
minute changeover sorry all right did I
see anything in here up there we go
I can't read that that's great okay
can't read it okay hate that 6-9 6-9
alright let's go ahead and hop to the
other free Wi-Fi
check check check check six six six six
six eleven okay that was the only wept
to here so it is now almost exactly oh
no wait oh I've popped that's right I
need to get this before before time runs
out cuz I am gonna run out of time on
this particular website I mean I'll just
have to wait until the next hour but I
do we need to get this in the next 10
minutes or so okay
did I get through all this I think I did
yep I did
okay so page three I'm not gonna bother
clicking on anything and I don't want to
look at that picture to be perfectly
honest
all right I think we can close that huh
okay is this page three okay let's look
through this
let me know if you guys see anything
because I'm gonna rely on you I don't
care if it's a delay I want to know do
you see something that's not an email
you think it's something good okay
I didn't see anything here I know that's
not a very thorough answer I know it's
not very thorough answer but it is now
officially time to start being hacked so
I'm gonna just go for we're gonna try
this bathroom cams website over and over
until we can get hooked and once we get
hooked you know I'm gonna win you know
I'm gonna win cuz I want the money okay
gimme some good easy xxx
oh yeah xxx xxx xxx I like xxx xxx is
good okay changing Wi-Fi changing to the
suite PF we've got about ten minutes on
this one Kinect
no Kinect okay we got that all right
where are we let's keep refreshing this
let's keep going on this I want I want
to be hacked hook me HECO me I'm gonna
get the wpa2 hack me hack me breath I
just saved Wi-Fi that's not for me
I just changed Wi-Fi that's not for me
you can't fool me you can't fool me I
know it's good I know what's good breath
I know it's good and that ain't for me
I just changed you cannot fool me I am
unfold all you cannot whoops you cannot
fool me
you can't fool me I know I know you're
about that's not for me thinks it can
trick me not today I'm too smart for you
I'm to my brains too big I got this big
old brain in my head I know that's not
for me I know that's a fake
I don't know so fake you think it's a
big old fakey fake biggest fake that
ever faked it's fine it's fine come on
give me something good I wanna be hacked
to be hacked
I wanna be hacked I wanna be hacked to
pieces wanna be hacked I wanna be hacked
I wanna be hacked oh one of it could be
see yeah I wanna be hacked it's not for
me it's not for me you guys are out of
your gourds stop being out of your
gourds come on hack me
come on hack me damn it somebody please
somebody please act me somebody please
please I'm begging you somebody want to
hack me we're just gonna get a hack come
on hack me I'm here or I want you to do
it come on please I'm begging you
no the FBI is not here but I'm gonna
need to change Wi-Fi pretty soon no
matter what I do
oh goodness gravy all right let's cycle
back to another Wi-Fi is cuz I don't
want to wait for it I don't like to be
left waiting but we're not gonna need to
crack another one before we do this okay
let's hope I have enough time and
whatever free Wi-Fi this is I don't even
need to be on the free duty duty
yeah dude he's good dude he's got about
10 minutes so let's open up the crack
again let's move this down
so I can see it up okay WEP scan here so
let me I make that noise sometimes I
make weird noises and I don't even
realize it okay let's keep going
hack me okay probe x0 p 8d p hell yeah 6
FP 0 1 do with us what the hell not prob
robe okay come on back me they do not
want to hack me they really don't want
to hack me it's [ __ ] come on I'm
gonna wait so long for this the cooldown
70 seconds it's supposed to initiate a
hack right away or pretty soon anyway
they didn't remove this bout that buddy
about time bout time buddy back got it I
think I got that she got that look how
much time I had on that god I'm getting
so good at that one ain't nobody gonna
be able to be me on that one
why say [ __ ] it up somehow that's good
I'm gonna get my wpa2 library okay now
that I got that let me switch wait oh no
I haven't even gotten into this one I
should be fine
to get into this one I'm gonna get into
this one cuz floater that's not very
long that's not very long yeah it's not
long that's not much time oh hey buddy
oh hi okay well
okay he's gone do-do-do-do-do t that's
why we look so much ok crack x0 what am
i typing this again that was outside me
house that saw my office that was not
here I think ok 9 5 7 go what oh god
damn it oh god damn it go okay we should
have more time we should have plenty of
time I'm just doing what I thought I saw
something I'm just doing that again
so that I can get that password really
quick I don't even remember which one
that was for that's for filter filter
that's fine and then we're gonna go back
to the other one
okay look Carter Nick Carter we're going
straight to it cuz I'm not whoa not that
one
we're going to Carter okay we're on okay
we're on okay let's scan for WPA let's
get out of this we need to get out of
that when you drop that note we need to
drop that uh oh wait I put it down there
that's right okay wpa2 scan it's
probably gonna take too long for us to
be in this one maybe we should now we
should be fine we've got about less than
10 minutes to do this and it shouldn't
take that long okay inject fat cloud
versus fat cloud that should be fine
tell my wife I I love her yeah let's do
fat cloud okay we're gonna go yeah we're
gonna do fat cloud okay yes 8v d TW 473
and 60
let's try to get hacked again okay we're
gonna wait that's a cool-down of seven
seconds in between each one so not very
long not very long at all
next up would be something else I know
no we're just trying to get enough money
to be able to get the key finder because
once we have the key finder then we comb
through everything that we don't need
anything else then it's just threats
inside the apartment okay now I'm
getting into the swing of this
I don't know when Lucas is gonna show up
but I have a funny feeling he's gonna
show up when we don't want him to but
that's fine I hope we have enough time
on this particular Wi-Fi but I don't
know if we will it's gonna be close I
don't like it I like it
oh no that was too long you know what I
I didn't like it anyway I'm not gonna go
to that one because I I just have a bad
feeling about that one so I'm gonna go
back to the original because the
original free Wi-Fi actually has the
longest duration of time it's almost 15
minutes that you can stay on the the
first free Wi-Fi and I believe that it
has a ton of WPA twos so if we keep
doing that that should be better for us
okay yes it does let's do the one we did
last time which was sniff Bewkes
inject one D na 6 3 var 3 channel 1
let's do 60 waiting 12 seconds in
between each one
come on why are these hacks taking so
long the hacks are taking forever and I
don't know why I really don't know there
we go Oh every time every time every
time come on
[ __ ] hell only 22 only $22 well
that's hardly any money at all that's
not any money give me more money please
hack me please I need more money I need
a lot more money I need a lot more money
I need a lot more money now 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve
this one's smooth all right Acme Acme
Acme yeah I think I think now that I'm
getting into the game like it's just
like this part that's gonna be tedious
just like getting this over and over
again getting hacked in the beginning
not yet not yet not just getting hacked
in the beginning and just like keeping
an eye out for everything listening for
Lucas cuz if I have no motion detector I
just gotta do by sound which is fine cuz
that's what I've been doing anyway it's
not like that's a challenge for me I can
just happen literally I've never heard
Lucas from emotion alert I've never
noticed Lucas from emotion alert it's
always been just me hearing him so it
must not be that bad I've only I've only
not heard him once so I'm willing to
risk that meanwhile I've died to the
breather every other time except for
last time
there we go I was just about to say I
was just about to say I will ever say
this is probably the last time I'm gonna
try tonight oh my god 99 baby Oh 99 yes
please
okay please give me into this when I
don't have a lot of time for this Wi-Fi
I need to get off of it I need to get
this I need to get into this one before
it's too late it is gonna be too late
I'm gonna get I'm gonna get swatted oh
god if I don't get this I'm gonna get
swatted why didn't I get this goddamn
I'm gonna get swatted I'm gonna get
swatted I'm gonna get swatted I'm gonna
gets wounded I'm gonna get swiggity
swooty ah god damn it not this okay I'm
gonna get swatted I'm so swatted I'm so
gonna be SWAT I'm still gonna be my
guess what I have enabled on that other
one so shouldn't be much longer though
it really shouldn't be much longer but
god damn it of course it's gonna be a
[ __ ] to me so now offline
god damn it off [ __ ] it anyway alright
well we'll just move back to a different
one then thank you for this goddamn
[ __ ] I guess I could still hack it
if I was off the Wi-Fi but god damn it
of course I [ __ ] that up [ __ ] okay
alright scan so [ __ ] I'm so pissed
all right let's do this again with only
one here
son of a [ __ ] in Jax XF no XF SZ d 8j
h97 channel 7 what do we have for this
one this is KP n well this one's the
small one so we can only do this one for
God I just [ __ ] put that in you
[ __ ] [ __ ] the clicking in the and
the interface is just such [ __ ] here
for this one's only gonna be four at a
time with a cool-down of four seconds oh
hi okay hello
that's peculiar I'm peeved
I'm bead I'm peeved
KPN hello 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4 5 oh
my god I really bones that up why are
you do that wait wait what just happened
what I bones it up but I didn't run out
of time
wait wait
i bones dip but I didn't bones it that
badly I couldn't have bones did that
badly 1 2 3 4 5 1 through 3 I clicked
the bomb I'll accidentally Emma's been
excellently whoops okay that makes sense
that makes sense I believe that I would
believe that I believe that I believe it
I believe it come on come on come on no
no no come on no no no no no no no
this game doesn't want me to win I mean
that's entirely my fault but scam
doesn't want me to win the game doesn't
want me to win game doesn't want me to
win the game doesn't want me to win game
just doesn't want me to win I can't win
how can I win how can I win ah I just
want to get into this free wife this
Wi-Fi let me into the Wi-Fi
Wi-Fi I gotta get a little Wi-Fi I just
got guys fine it's fine guys it's fine
it's fine let's go get another wife and
I get into the Wi-Fi later we're fine
I get into the Wi-Fi everything will be
forgiven
okay I thought I heard something I get
I'm out of back doors I see that I'm out
of back doors good call good call good
catch good catch good catch you saved me
some pain
all right let's back on our Wi-Fi oh do
we have PFW we do don't we buy back
there's good call good call good call
good call good call good call good call
good call good call good call good call
good call good call good call
door locks good call good call no [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you oh here we go
crack okay we're gonna connect to a WPA
I keep hearing I keep hearing a single
footstep it's messing with me getting so
paranoid
okay muffin ma Finn okay we're gonna
connect to KPN oh the long honk I don't
like it I don't like it you know I don't
like it at all
man if I hadn't lost those two hacks I
would have been there already I would
have been starting on the key train
whatever fine what can you do
I suppose you can do this real fast
that's nice come on hack me hack me damn
it
yeah how long I can be on kpn I can only
be on kpn for a little over 10 minutes
to be perfectly honest I shouldn't stay
on here very long but I can hop back
over to the main one soon
come on hack me Jesus hack me
I feel like I feel like a piece of [ __ ]
doing this strategy why not just do the
normal one then I'd get it when I get it
why not just play the game the way the
big game is never mind
[Music]
okay don't click on the death of doing
any of this I have to change wise again
and so I'm such I'm such a mangry boy
I'm angry Oh God let's try this again
yeah okay it's the same one boy I've got
nothing left to my name I did it wrong
from the very GetGo of this [ __ ]
maybe I should just go out on my balcony
and wish for death maybe that's what I
should do maybe I should wish for death
huh maybe I should just hope hope and
pray hope and pray that death claims me
it's the only thing I have going for me
anymore
oh I hope and wish I wish for death I
wish I wish for death I crave it
I crave death someone please grant me a
merciful death
I'm struggling yes I am struggling I'm
struggling real hard cuz I feel like I
would be better off if I was just
playing the game and not doing this too
bad cuz I would still be hacked I would
still be hacked regularly and because I
would be hacked about as much as I would
be hacked right now and yet I would get
more money because like I'm not being
gonna be stupid about it I don't know
you know I don't know I don't know
anymore I don't know anything I don't
know who I am where I am I'm lost that's
different that looks weird I hate life I
hate life Lukas kill me kill me Lucas
just kill me kill me straight-up kill me
Lucas I'm gonna hide in the closet next
time Lucas come I'm just gonna hide in
the closet that's all I'm gonna do Lucas
kill me kill me please kill me kill me
now
[Music]
I didn't even want to play this game
this style because oh god here we go
again
whoops where what oh oh oh oh oh no I
bugged it i bugged it told you this game
was broken god damn it then I get a
hundred and one then I get a hundred oh
hey how's it going there a friend it's
fine the police are gonna get me I know
the police are gonna give me okay the
police are gonna get me get me
I know they are they're gonna come get
me maybe I want him too
maybe I want him too now you know what
maybe I want it maybe I'm asking for it
I did this all wrong I should have had I
should have had the two
[Music]
well now it's dark you know what I'm
gonna go I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
sit on my balcony just I'm just gonna
sit on my balcony I'm gonna think about
what I've done I'm gonna just go guy
here I'm just gonna go over here go up
here sometimes I just stare out at this
beautiful city when I just remember that
I'm an [ __ ] I remember I distinctly
remember how much of a douche I Hey look
I'm now the skull guy look I'm oh this
guy was smart he put [ __ ] in front of
his window oh yeah well what a smarty
hey neighbor
you got any murderers murderers next to
you you got any murderers murderers head
of right burners I've never heard of the
word murderers before hmm
can I go all the way wait how far can I
go - oh only this far down what's the
point of this - what is the point of
being able to go out on the balcony like
there's got to be a mechanic that does
something right Oh a bottle of wine a
you know I see how you are I'm peeping
peeping I'm hoping for an Easter egg or
something of what is that a giant
baseball bat a rug I'm just in despair
that's all I am it's my apartment
oh no I'm just in despair I'm just in
pure despair just somebody kill me
somebody end my torment I locked it
who's gonna who's gonna kill me kill me
somebody kill me somebody do it I'm
gonna go out into the alley I'm gonna go
out in the alley gonna go out in the
alley I'm gonna hope for the breather to
come kill me I just want this to end I
just want the suffering to end he's one
of the suffering to end and be done with
this cuz I started this off really badly
because I didn't get the WEP I should
have gotten the WEP or I had the WEP I
should have cracked the codes in the
beginning of the thing I should have
done that I don't even need to go
outside for any particular reason I know
how to beat this game and none of it
involves you don't need to buy a single
thing all you need is software to be
able to beat this game I almost on 2%
guarantee you only need a software
because I
oh we're yet we're yet buddy we're yet
oh not here
Oh what why why come on come on don't be
shy
bbbbbb okay I didn't even want to win on
that one like I think I got it but
unfortunately I'm out of time for today
I was I was out of time I had to end it
I had to end it there because I was out
of time and I did it stupidly but next
time next time I do know how to beat
this game I bet I bet in the next time I
can beat this game because I know how to
beat all the threats I know how to do it
I know how to crack the Wi-Fi I got
unlucky with the Noir there it would
have been fine but I didn't if I just
play it normally I'll get hot enough we
got any time to agenda you know what you
mean guys you know I mean okay I'm Audi
I'm Audi I gotta get going but thank you
everybody so much for being here
smashed give us smooch that like if you
think that I can do it next time
I don't know oh I just don't know but
thank you everybody so much for watching
I appreciate you all of your help and
living through my desperation but I'll
get through this next step so thanks
again and as always I'll see you in the
next video bye